[Music]
whether heading across the country or
taking a weekend getaway people love to
travel regardless of the destination
it's impossible to leave home without
luggage luggage is made from all kinds
of materials including wood metal
plastic high-tech polycarbonates and
leather not all Lea overnight bags are
created
equal this dark brown bag was
constructed with the capacity to hold
water the process starts with full grain
hides Chrome tanned by an outside
facility Chrome tanning is an effective
treatment which allows the leather to
become more water
resistant this bag is constructed from a
single piece of leather making it more
durable and
watertight first a leather worker uses a
template to cut out the shape of the bag
[Music]
he uses a machine to shave the edges off
the piece of leather in a process called
skying which prepares the leather for
folding and sewing using a hole punch
another Craftsman Taps the series of
openings for riveting on buckles and
other
attachments the holes will prevent the
opening from
[Music]
ripping next a leather worker uses a
template to Mark where he'll apply a
strip of glue to the top
Edge he attaches a polyester strip to
the bottom edge of the
glue and spreads more glue on top of the
polyester then he folds and hammers the
top portion of the leather over onto the
polyester
strip once complete the leather worker
trims the edges of the
polyester the leather is then placed
into a machine known as a clicker to
Stamp Out the bag straps and other
leather
components the clicker works by applying
25 tons of pressure to custommade
dyes the shoulder pad is one of 22
pieces of leather that will complete the
bag a craft person glues a foam
rectangle between two layers of leather
this type of glue won't bubble in high
temperatures Chrome taned hide is tough
stuff so manufacturers use a heated
stamp to Brand the leather with their
logo
a leather worker uses a sewing machine
to piece together multiple parts of the
leather the stitching perforations
weakens the Leather So for added
strength the Craftsman uses a heavy
gauge continuous filament polyester
thread next a Craftsman attaches the
buckles he places one steel rivet in
each Buckle piece and secures it into
place he leaves the remaining rivets out
to accommodate the sewing machine which
will reinforce the attachment the
buckles are made of high strength 316
stainless
[Music]
steel a Craftsman attaches a piece of
plastic to reinforce the handle and
prevent the leather from becoming
misshapen over
time once he's glued in pieces P of
plastic to each handle
opening the leather worker finishes all
the
seams this type of continuous filament
polyester thread is the same kind that
is used to sew parachutes
together next a craftswoman cleans the
completed bag and applies a generous
amount of leather milk to condition the
leather the leather milk is made of all
natural non-toxic
[Music]
ingredients the craft woman uses a torch
to singe off any stray hairs before the
strap is attached to a set of upper or
lower
d-rings this versatile bag can now be
worn as a backpack or a shoulder
bag stylish and durable this leather
overnight bag is built to hold your
stuff while you travel to any
destination
air hockey was developed in the late 60s
and early' 7s by a group of American
Billiard Engineers when in play the puck
floats on a thin cushion of air
propelled by players at each end with no
friction the puck moves fast making air
hockey a high-speed
game in a game of air hockey the puck
levitates ever so slightly made possible
by a constant flow of air flowing
through perforations in the
Playfield the Playfield is made from a
laminated composite material that's been
printed with air hockey
Graphics a computerized drill cuts into
three playfields at once in the same
consistent
pattern the size of the holes are a
little larger than pin holes creating
over 4,600 perforations in each air
hockey Playfield
an automated tool carves grooves in a
sheet of medium density
fiberboard the board will serve as a
base for the
Playfield air will circulate in the
grooves and exit through the Playfield
holes next sawdust is blasted out of the
grooves the grooves fiber board moves
through a glue
applicator the rubber roller coats the
top of the board with a small amount of
glue so it doesn't seep into the
grooves as the board exits technicians
move the board onto a
stack once the board is in the correct
position the laminate is applied and
aligned with the grooves in the
[Music]
fiberboard a cardboard cover is placed
on the laminate for protection as the St
stack moves through a
press the weight of the press squeezes
the stack together ensuring adhesion as
the glue
cures meanwhile a craftswoman applies
stick on Graphics onto the side apron
boards she opens a pre-cut slot for a
coin door and exposes a hole for a
bolt she cuts open a slide for
maintenance access and removes the panel
that will serve as a
door she numbers the door in the side
apron piece so she can match them up
later during
[Music]
installation after applying artwork to
the end panels another technician
assembles curved Corner
parts and links metal brackets to the
side apron
Parts he installs a bracket for a puck
deflector in the center of the end
panel and screws down the corner
connectors he sets the end panels in an
upside down position on the work
surface and attaches the sideboards to
the corner
connectors this completes the table
apron a locked door is installed in the
plywood floor this will serve as an
interior storage
compartment next a Craftsman installs
the coin door and secures it into
place he mounts wire speakers that
project sound effects to a computerized
Optical system that tracks the Puck's
movements once the structure is fitted
with wooden panels the the game's
flashing lights and sensor activators
are
installed at another station a team
flips a Playfield over to work on the
back one technician attaches a board
above the open grooves creating a
chamber for air
flow the motor and fan are installed
over the small opening this system will
blow air into the grooves and the
Playfield
perforations the Playfield is turned
over and lowered onto the table
structure next aluminum bumpers are
attached to the table's border as a
barrier for the puck during
play a technician installs goal puck
deflectors on the
ends and screws in metal plates over the
deflector
cups he installs a lock on each go
compartment so no one can steal the
puck
finally the air hockey table assembly is
complete let the games
[Music]
begin